في صحيفتها ارس نجد ان الحرب ضد حماس كشفت
عن حاجه اسرائيل اكثر من اي وقت مضى الى
المساعدات الامريكيه يحذر المقال من ان
حربا اخرى مع حزب الله تعني حاجتها للمزيد
من الدعم العسكري الامريكي الحرب في غزه
كشفت فجوه كبيره في الانتاج العسكري
الاسرائيلي وبينما لا يمكن تدارك هذا
النقص في وقت قريب يخاطر الاعتماد على
واشنطن بمنحها مساحه اوسع للتدخل في سير
الصراع ويضع اسرائيل في منافسه مع دول
اخرى مثل اوكرانيا لتامين القدر الكافي من
الاسلحه والذخيره جيروسالم بوست كتبت ان
عهد نتنياهو انتهى وقالت استنادا لمصادرها
ان هناك اعتقادا متزايدا بان ايام نتنياهو
على راس الحزب اصبحت معدوده رغم محاوله
تشكيل جبهه لدعمه قاعده الحزب تعتقد ان
نتنياهو لن يفي بوعوده بتدمير حماس
واستعاده جميع الرهائن
واعضاء من حزب الليكود في الكنيست يعملون
خلف الكواليس مع خلفاء محتملين لنتنياهو
والانفجار السياسي حسب الصحيفه اقرب للسطح
مما يبدو ويمكن ان يحدث في غضون اسبوعين
الى شهرين تناول تقرير لصحيفه واشنطن بوست
ازمه الاتصالات في قطاع غزه في ظل الحرب
المستمره واثرها في مفاقمه معاناه السكان
جاء في التقرير ان الانقطاعات المتكرره في
شبكه الهاتف تعوق تنسيق عمليات الاجلاء
معقده اصلا وتزيد من تحديات من يسعون
للاطمئنان على اقاربهم ومعارفهم باي وسيله
او تامين بعض حاجياتهم اما الصحفيون
فيجدون صعوبه في محاولاتهم اطلاع العالم
على حجم المعاناه داخل القطاع صحيفه
الجارديان سلطت الضوء على تقرير للجنه
حمايه الصحفيين وضع اسرائيل ضمن قائمه
اسوا سجاني
الصحفيين حسب الصحيفه يضع التصنيف اسرائيل
مع مجموعه من سيئه السمعه من الدول
الاستبداديه التي لها تاريخ في سجن
الصحفيين وذلك بسبب احتجازها الصحفيين
فلسطينيين دون محاكمتهم منذ بدايه الحرب
في غزه التقرير يذكر ان الاعتقال عينه من
المخاطر التي تتهدد الصحفيين الفلسطينيين
في غزه يستبعد تقرير في مجله ايكونوميست
ان تؤدي العقوبات الامريكيه الى تغيير
سلوك الحوثيين في البحر الاحمر ويعتبرها
اداه ضعيفه اثبتت فشلها خلال السنوات
الماضيه في الضغط عليهم يشير التقرير الى
ان للحوثيين ان يلتفوا على العقوبات
ويحصلوا على الموارد الضروريه وعلى المزيد
من الاسلحه ويعزز التقرير طرحه بالقول ان
المسؤولين الامريكيين يعترفون سرا بان
تهديد الحوثيين للشحن البحري سيظل قائما